Okay, everyone. I am Kushan.
I worked at Seraphim as a founding
engineer for 2 years. Let's talk about
what I'm interested in right now, and
that is browser agents.
Browser agents as an idea are so cool,
right? The browser agent should go
crazy, right? I personally have not seen
that adoption, and me myself, I don't
use browser agents that much. I've been
exploring that for some time. I've been
trying to understand why that is. So, on
my screen right now, we have the browser
challenge.
But, this is a very interesting
benchmark for browser agents because
there are so many things that you have
to do, long rising sequencing of your
tasks. And this actually reveals, you
know, why browser agents suck. If you
saw at the beginning of the video,
the browser this agent took like maybe
10-20 seconds just to click the start
button. And now, we're on step one.
There are 30 steps, and it has taken so
long just to click one button.
Um so, enough of this. I want to show
you what I've been building. So, same
website.
Um I've tried to sort of replicate the
feeling of seeing what's happening, you
know, you can see what the browser agent
is thinking. But as you can see, it is
so much faster and so much quicker, and
I'm using a much cheaper model, right?
The hypothesis here is models are pretty
smart, but it's the infra around them
that sucks. If you noticed in the video
earlier, maybe I'll put a screenshot,
the agent is trying to debug what's
going on. It's trying to click
something, but it doesn't understand
what's going on. So, my core thesis here
has been
give a nice environment for the agent to
use, right? So, where it can plan long
sequences, it can figure out where it
failed, what is going on, and it can
plan the click correctly. I figured out
is a cool representation which
compresses the website and lets the
agent see the entire page in very few
few tokens. Now, I want to show you some
actual examples. Let's say I want to
download my Aadhaar. Um so, this is
Claude trying to do it. So, I'd assume
that this is very simple for a browser
agent. I take a screenshot, you see the
button right there, click it. Uh but
then, what's interesting is that it got
stuck after this point. So, from 46
seconds until the end of this video, it
took a screenshot, it scrolled for some
reason, it took a screenshot.
Basically, this entire process took 2
minutes, whereas
in my case, in our video,
so, it just boots, and
boom, done.
And that's the beauty of a browser
agent. Just how quick was that? And I'm
using such a cheap model for this.
Another interesting example is So, my
friends and I are going trekking on
on Sunday. I was wondering, you know
what? Because this this site is in
Canada and I am not very fluent in
Canada.
Like it took me some time to figure out
this website. So, I asked Claude like,
"Hey, can you book this for me?" And by
the end of it, it's unable to pick a
date and it just stuck. This is the
video of my agent.
You can see it selects it and
puts in the date and boom, done. Right?
It's so simple and convenient to use in
theory. So, what's next, right? What am
I planning on doing? I'm thinking of
open sourcing this project because again
my this code is not super defensible.
The product that I want to give is again
maybe an API that as you can see we were
running these commands. Maybe I just
want to expose this command as an API.
Give me a URL, give me your intent and I
will execute it for you and give it back
to you and or maybe open this as a
website
or expose this as a plugin. But yeah, so
bottom line is I want to make browser
agents faster, cheaper and more reliable
and just make sure everybody in the
world is using them because they can
just do so much for you.
So yeah, that's the broad idea here.
Thank you for watching.
This
entire
markdown
presents the website, that particular
page. And let's actually do this
interesting comparison, right? Let's go
to AIS. The full DOM for this would be
around 20,000 tokens. But so, let's say
we have this screenshot.
All right, this screenshot's about 1,100
tokens.
My markdown's about 1,800 tokens and
instead in one screenshot where you
could see only one particular snippet,
you can see the entire
website, right? A couple of other things
that it's important to give feedback,
right? So, we say that okay, hey, these
are the new things that have popped up
on the page. This is now gone, right?
And similarly, we can say that you know,
this thing that was blocking up things
that you wanted to click has now been
removed. You know, we give it feedback
that you tried to click this, but that
didn't happen because you know, we're
keeping track of the entire end-to-end
browser
page.
Right? So, all of this together, what I
built is a very clean representation
that that basically compresses the
website, and you can give this along
with the screenshot. It's pretty cheap
token-wise. Um so, the model can reason
really well, and then it can construct
this long sequence of tasks to execute.